[Music]
on today's show we talk to a young man
who wants to develop community in his
new town we talk to a woman who wonders
if her relationship with her ex is good
for their son we talked to an incredible
young woman who is bravely clawing her
way back to a new relationship stay
tuned
[Music]
what up what up
this is john with the dr john deloney's
show
show about you your mental health your
relationships your marriages parenting
idiots that you work with your friends
i don't know whatever's going on
zach sarah it's good to see everybody
kelly
jameth
one of the hiding engineers back there
it's good to see everybody
we're back in town today after a long
wild weekend and uh
weekend i guess it's been a whole week i
don't even know what day it is anymore
but i'm glad to have everybody hey james
kelly i have a quick question so on the
internets last night um there was
another study and they got a bunch of
these and i i mean i think they're
largely accurate
about
the amount of
when you have a two
uh um two people who are full-time and
full-time employed that often the woman
takes the continues to take the lion's
share of the work at home
and so
if you ask a guy how much he thinks how
much he's helping at home he'll say like
it's 50 50. and then they'll follow him
around and actually it's like
90 10 that she takes on the line show
the work at home so basically she works
two full-time jobs
and i had this thought last night for
the first time and so i'm gonna go ahead
and get us canceled today um as a show i
want to tell everybody it's been fun but
i want to get y'all's opinion on this
so
how much of
the work that goes on domestically
and i can see kelly the lasers are
starting to form as like a like an old
robot
um how much of the work domestically is
work that is
because things have to be a certain way
or they have to look a certain way at a
regular time so for instance my wife and
i have had discussions about like can
you help around the kitchen and i would
say absolutely
a lot of that has to do with the fact
that the kitchen has to be done every
single day in a certain way
and so when there's x amount of work
done in the house if we were to measure
it out to be 90 10 i'm thinking
we do the dishes a lot seven times a
week versus let's do them three times a
week
and then it would be more 50 does that
make sense
yeah it does and i'm i'm very guilty of
that
so and there's a lot of things my
husband does that
we've kind of over the years have worked
it out that there's some things i'm like
you know what i'm just going to do that
because i want it done my way
yes or if we vacuumed once a month
i mean it would be kind of gross but it
would get done versus what we need to
vacuum every week or every other day
and then yes and then it looks out of
whack
yeah i mean if i think if somebody
looked at it at our house it would look
out of whack but i know it's not because
there's other things he does like he
tends to go
to more doctor's appointments and things
like that with our daughter
because his schedule is more flexible
yeah whereas i do more things around the
house because if he doesn't i'm just
going to redo them or i'm going to get
ticked about it so i'm just going to do
it so i will because i know that's my
thing that's not on him that's on me i'm
i i wonder i don't know if that study
exists and i don't know that anybody
would have the guts to do that actually
say that james what do you think i see
you hiding back there i'm sorry i was
working on my resume
exactly why can't coleman resume
builders.com
is that
i think there's some air to that um not
necessarily
at my house i feel like we
we both do things around the house
no i don't i don't think so but i think
the point i think your point is valid
and i think we should commission that
study
all right i'm going to stay as far away
from that study i just occurred to me
last night like because
when i lived with a house full of
moronic guys back in college and right
after college
i wasn't like it was barely livable but
if things got fin got done right we and
uh somebody eventually has to do the
dishes we play poker game somebody loses
or we throw them all out and get new
ones or whatever however that worked
somebody finally has to mow the yard
when the when the
neighborhood association calls or
something i just i don't know i'm
wondering so here's what i want you to
do everybody listen to the show
if you're um a man listening to the show
i want you to go home and be like we're
50 50 right i want you just to lead with
that
and if you're a woman watching this show
i want you to go home and
i don't know hit your husband or
something like that does that sound good
don't hit no hit i've gotten in trouble
for that don't hit anybody
um go home and
i don't know i don't know how to get out
of this now now we're stuck write poems
right palms all right let's go to allen
in austin is that a good way to get out
of here let's go to alan what's up alan
how are you
you know i'm all things considered doing
pretty well how about you dr deloney we
are having a party
what's up man how are you
doing all right the big question that i
had for you today is you've mentioned it
a lot on your show about the importance
of community yeah and how important that
is for like mental well-being but also
especially when you're going through
trials and tribulations
so my question is
how do you go about building a community
from scratch
when you've never actually done that
before oh that's a good question
so are you moving somewhere or are you
how old are you
i'm imminently twenties like
yeah i'm actually heading out to a new
city here in a few months okay and
so walk me through the communities
you've had in the past or lack of you've
just never had a gang
not really i mean i've had
individual friendships that have been
very
supportive and very close
but i feel like
when you have a friendship that's just
too much one-on-one you run the risk of
their becoming an imbalance
what does that mean and
an imbalance where the focus shifts too
much either on your needs or their needs
and
historically have not been very good
at
striking a balance and therefore
i've been inclined to either become
resentful and just
drop friendships
or vice versa
so do you
and we'll get to the community questions
so this is going to help me get to
build us a bridge to get there
um
are you somebody that
is a lot
for other people or do you end up
getting so absorbed in other people's
world that
you wake up one day and you're so buried
by their stuff that you can't move
i totally become enmeshed okay i'm a lot
and i
i know that
in the past
um
people and by the past i mean like last
week or so um i i'm a lot
i can
i'm excitable and i always have new
ideas i want to talk about and i like
debating and i like hollering and i'm
loud and in and so i'm a lot you like to
get in other people's lives and then
also you find yourself up underwater
uh yeah 100 that's what happened with my
last relationship
okay um
why do you do that
by the way if you were if we were in a
like a true counseling session you're
not ever allowed to ask that question
but since we're on the radio we'll just
break that rule um what why do you
immerse yourself in the lives of other
people what about your life
is lacking to the word you want to live
through other people until you just
can't
i guess a lot of it is
related to
kind of my own sense of value okay
and i i say that having done a lot of
reflection on my past
uh like this week i wrote close to 16
000 words going through kind of the
whole gamut of it all yeah
and
that was kind of a tendency that popped
up was
my needs
like in childhood didn't really matter
and so as a consequence of that
you know if i find someone that seems to
value me for some reason
then it becomes easy to kind of cling on
to them because at least for a time
you know you're valuable to someone ah
so you almost become a vampire until you
just completely drain them of everything
and
then nobody's got anything left
i mean i say that but at the same time i
definitely give a lot to try to maintain
uh the relationship until i get to the
point where i realize no matter how much
i can
provide
that ultimately my needs are not woven
into the fabric of the relationship
gotcha
and therefore it comes kind of that
breaking point right of deciding
should i stay or should i go
so are your needs worth being met
my inclination is to say yes
i'll i'll ask that again
are your needs worth are your needs
worth being met
uh yeah yeah
fully full stop
exclamation point at the end unless
you're an attorney then there's just a
period at the end
yeah
for sure so
one of the challenges i run into by
talking about how important it is for
people to have relationships and have
community to have a gang to have
intimate connection with one person
to have um peripheral friends that you
can show up with and nod to and you know
split meals with and things like that
is
i fall into a trap and this is me i fall
into a trap of saying here's the benefit
of that
the benefit is you live longer the
benefit is is your
mental health is better your physical
health is better and on and on and on
the the problem i run into is it tends
to put an roi on it
so
people start looking for other people
because it's gonna meet their needs not
just to be with people does that make
sense
so yeah it's making it more
transactional there you go and so my
fear is that there's we're in what i
think is
a glitch in the matrix for all of human
history
with the current loneliness epidemic and
this is way before cove it happened
but we are so isolated and our brains
have no it is just ringing every bell in
our bodies
whether it's the anxiety bell the
depression bell the you name it it is
chaos
and we're passing this on to our kids
and we're having it passed on by our our
um parents this loneliness loneliness
and our brains are designed for that
the challenge is when i tell you know
millions of people hey you need to have
some relationships
because of these reasons then it's kind
of like you know it's like networking or
it is i need to get my my oil change so
my car won't stop
and so i think that the challenge for
you is twofold number one
you're gonna have to
let go
of the lie that it was told to you
either affirmatively or just through
neglect nobody told you anything
that your needs aren't worth being met
they absolutely are
so in your that's that's lie number one
or that's that's thing number one you're
gonna have to accept it
and what this means is you've been
carrying stuff around for
almost 30 years you're gonna have to
decide
my needs are worth being met
and the challenge for you man is it just
it kind of feels easier to go through
life like
not speaking up for yourself not being
disappointed in other people not being
disappointed in yourself it's easier
just to kind of float around
and so in the last when you wrote in
those 16 pages what are some needs you
came up with
that you need
you know it's funny i
talked about how all of my needs either
weren't met but i didn't necessarily i
get to the point of identifying
what i actually need
i think if i'm just going off the top of
my head
uh
i would say
uh acceptance
in terms
i i tend to be as smart alec as my
grandma used to call me you would you
should probably apply for a job here
you'd be great on our team
yes
i'm keeping an eye on it baby um
but uh
like being accepted for my
ridiculous commentary on just random
things
again but all yes you should probably
join our team yeah
but i do that for a living by the way
allen i make a living with ridiculous
commentary so there's a place for you
yes
well i'd say you're living the dream
then yes i'm um
until today's show which probably is
probably gonna put an end to us here's
the i want you to write down
and be really explicit about
what your needs are
and what you're going to find is it's
going to distill down into two things
that you are fully known that you can be
honest about the things that make you
laugh the things that make you upset in
the world
the things that make you feel wanted the
main things that make you feel excluded
and you can all those things are going
to matter and you're going to want to
have all those things and still be loved
still be known
my guys my buddies in my life who i've
been with for years and decades and
decades and decades
will roll their eyes asked taloni
that's stallone oh look doloney fell
asleep again in the middle of the fight
stallone fell asleep again in the middle
of dinner the lonely fill in the blank
right
they know me and then they still love me
that's that's the big one number one
number two is you're gonna have to
risk
and i
get the sense just your cadence you
don't like risk are you risk avoidant
uh i tend to be i work in finances so
there you go there you go
in that camp i'm all about mitigation
yes
and so here's the thing as you go to a
new community here's a couple of things
i will um recommend for you so i want to
back out number one i want you to be
super clear about your needs what do you
need as you navigate the world
i need people to hold me accountable i
need people who will laugh
love love love laughing i love people
who will be graceful with on the margins
with me
um because i tend to be a lot but i also
hit the guard rails sometimes or i'm 10
minutes late here five minutes late
there or whatever the thing is so know
what your needs are
and then decide
decide
i'm gonna start speaking up on them i'm
gonna start being heard i'm not gonna go
through my life keeping secrets from
everybody around me
and that's gonna keep you from drowning
people
because you hang on hang on hang on hang
on and that person can't tread water for
two people and then the second thing is
you're gonna have to risk so here's a
couple of things as you head out
number one you're gonna have to go first
you're gonna have to show up in a new
place whether that is a
look for shared experiences whether
that's joining a team whether that is uh
church community work softball jiu jitsu
class uh i'll even say a uh crossfit
class
um what do you go you go to yellow
theories that was a funny joke orange
theory what any kind of color theory
that you would like to go to
um
play guitar i don't whatever it is
um
find a group that you can have shared
experiences with and then you got to go
first
just show up
and it might make your heart rate it go
up it might be uncomfortable it might be
weird you may find out early in that you
don't like it they don't like you and
you're going to have to grieve it accept
it wash off the rejection and go again
and go again and go again
but it's going to be a matter of putting
yourself out there and when you know
yourself when you're not trying to
silence your needs so that somebody else
will have you in their presence
and then over time your needs start to
come out and that person's like that's
not what i signed up for and then
there's that rejection loop if you can
know
i'm alan from austin and allen and
wherever you're gonna end up st louis or
wherever you're going
and i like these things i think this is
funny i think this is stupid i think
these people are hilarious i think these
people aren't that funny when you can
put your throw your shoulders back put
your head up high and say i'm just alan
this is this is the things i like and
the things i don't like and you can
navigate into any space
of course you're going to be
fearful of rejection rejection is awful
i hate it everybody hates it nobody
likes rejection but you can go into
those groups and say hey man what's up
this is me let's do jiu jitsu or let's
play on the softball team i'm terrible
at softball by the way i'll strike out a
hundred percent of the time
but i will throw my glove at you or i
will make jokes out in the outfield
while i'm missing the ball whatever the
thing is
and then if they have you back great and
if they don't you can grieve it and go
man that sucks i really like hanging out
with that group of people and then you
can go on to the next
thing is knowing your needs matter
they do
knowing what they actually are and then
going first no rejections coming
and go share some experiences with
people man thank you so much for call
and we'll be right back on the john
delonay show
[Music]
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john dolone show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we're back let's go to jessica
in denver hey jessica what's happening
hi dr dalomi how are you
good how are you just couldn't be having
more fun
okay
so i have a question for any time
somebody starts a call with
okay
it's usually a good one
yeah i um
so here it is um my son's father and i
um decided to separate when he was six
months when my son is six months okay
and now he's ten months
so at that point at six months he moved
out of the house and
we find ourselves on spending a lot of
time together are y'all divorced
no we weren't married we had been
together for about
um six years lived together for four of
those years
um so we never were legally married um
to just
cohabiting and
we decided why'd you all break up
so there's a
a number of things but i think the three
events that just
i couldn't come back from where
um the biggest one was i got really bad
postpartum depression afterwards and i
just didn't feel supported
by him
one of the times he actually
um
made a comment once that
i was weak like a weak mom and that
really
like hit me so hard i remember just like
feeling like a punch to my stomach
because i was feeling weak and i was
feeling like um like i wasn't a good mom
so when he
told me those words
i like went into my closet and just
cried
and
he seen me crying and he never like he
didn't say anything to me he actually
said something about um
like stop crying i'm not gonna feel bad
for you because you're crying
and
i think that was a turning point for me
because i um
had thoughts of
not being worthy like not being like my
son deserves a better mom
so
the next day after that happened
i
i realized that those thoughts just
were so extreme like i have never
had thoughts like that so i reached out
to a therapist
and um
yeah so i started seeing a therapist and
the other event that was pretty
significant um
was
in december
of 2019
he
was unfaithful
he was going to
um get some like massages at a
like a massage parlor
place
and i found out about those
and um
so just there was no trust
either
like i got a massage yesterday are you
talking about like yeah but these were
yeah these were like happy ending
massages uh okay they were sexualized
massages okay yeah okay and um like he
told me about them and so there was no
trust and then i think the last um the
last thing that i can
say that really just like we tried
everything to be together um
was couples therapy so i have started my
own individual therapy he started his
individual therapy
and we seeked out a really good couples
therapist and we had been going to some
sessions and in one of those sessions he
decided to just walk out like he was so
upset and he walked out of the session
and i thought he went to go get a
breather but when i looked we were at
home
doing on a video call but when i looked
out the window he had actually left yeah
and
to me that was so rejecting
so
after that i told him i'm still willing
to do couple therapy but you have to
schedule the next one and he just never
did so we were both just full of
resentment
and
couldn't stand each other anymore like
he had been sleeping on the couch for
over a month and a half before we
separated
and we talked and both came to the
decision that it just was not working
for us that we could not
be living together anymore yeah so here
so here you're here now you got a 10
month old
and yeah
i'm going to make a guess i'm going to
make a guess
y'all aren't broken up
but you're broke we really are we've
actually discussed not
getting back together anymore um we both
decided that and so recently he invited
us to california with him
and i really want to go i was excited
and i mentioned it to my mom and she
actually
said
um she made a comment about how i am
setting a bad example for my son
that i'm teaching him what relationships
are like and a wrong way because we're
not together and we don't plan on being
back together and but i'm pretty much
going to scar him
so my question to you was
am i setting a bad example for my son
like should i not be spending as much
time with his son being that we don't
plan on getting back together
i don't believe you that you're not
planning on getting back together
that's just me um have y'all okay so you
all broke up um four months ago i guess
five months ago is that right yes yeah
have you all slept together in that five
months
yes have you all done we have been in
the past like three months two months
okay great congratulations
have you ever gone to dinner or coffee
or when he comes to see his child do
y'all
do you just go to
yeah yeah
i don't believe you is what i'm saying
that's not a bad thing i still am your
friend and i would still hang out too
i just don't believe you
and i think somewhere in there
y'all got crossways y'all got sideways
and he didn't know how to
handle being a new dad and it scared the
crap out of him
postpartum depression is a
just nightmare
and he didn't have the tools to navigate
that and said stupid things
and he's probably doing his own crap
and he was unfaithful and and and and my
guess is
you've got challenges too is that fair
are you alive
yes yes i am you are i am too that's
welcome to the unlock club and so here's
what i'm thinking um i'm thinking that
this is a tough season and it's
frustrating and it's been really
peaceful
to
not have to deal with that and you still
love this guy a lot
and or you're connected to this guy that
doesn't mean you have to be married to
him it doesn't mean blah blah blah
but i think that there is still a part
of you that's not fully done here here's
where the challenge is for your son
it's the sun right i just made that up
it's the sun
yeah
and again this is putting a lot on a 10
month old which isn't isn't fair
um but over time
there's always this childhood fantasy
that my parents will get back together
at some point
and often and this is with a little bit
older kids um
they will do whatever they can to try to
make that to facilitate people coming
back together
and that's not a burden that a child
is designed to carry should ever have to
carry it's um unfair
and the other side of that is
when
um
when two adults separate and there's
kids involved and they act like adults
and they treat each other with dignity
and they treat each other with respect
they make the best of an awful situation
then um that's better for kids
what you have to decide is where your
relationship is if you go to a on a trip
to california with him
y'all will end up being together you
know this he knows this everybody knows
this you know who else knows your mom
knows this
and now america knows this
and so
i i want you to be honest with yourself
about why you're going
is there a part of you that hopes he
calls and or why y'all are on the way to
california he's like hey i've been i've
been in counseling and i'm sorry for the
things i said
there's a i guarantee you there's a part
of you that really hopes that that that
conversation happens
and you may have learned some things in
counseling that you hope he asks about
so you can tell them am i am i tell me
i'm way off and say dylan you're an
idiot or am i right
i um
so i enjoy his company a lot so you
enjoy his competition
okay so jessica what would he what would
it take what would he have to say
like he calls you and says i'm coming
over this morning
what would he say to you and you were
like all right i'm all back in
i can feel it on you through the phone
that you are one centimeter from being
all back in but he just has to do a
couple things what are those things
i um
no i just don't think that it would work
out i mean it's just the type of person
that he is
um i know i know all that i know all
that and you've you're that's awesome
what would he have to say
for you to be like all right i'm back
and that he's willing to do i knew
yes i knew it though i knew it so here's
the thing
here's what your mom is correct
there is gonna be relational modeling
and if your son learns that there will
always be that women will hang on and
hang on and hang on and hang on and dad
can leave and do whatever dad wants to
do
and then swoop back in then swoop back
out
and mom is going to continue to hang on
and hang on and hang on you are correct
there will be a modeling that's going on
about this is how relationships work
um your son is not going to listen to
you as much as he's going to watch you
he's not going to listen to dad as much
as he watches
dad the other side of that is
i think that your relationship is still
salvageable as crazy as that sounds
i don't know him i'd have to talk to him
and he's obviously working through some
demons he's got some stuff but he's
gotta gotta navigate
but i don't think the whole thing's over
i do think while you are in limbo land
it is not smart for you to treat him
like a boyfriend
okay
and here's the other thing can i say
something scary
because you've been through a lot
i don't think
you are broken or weak or dysfunctional
or not a strong powerful single mom
if you sit down and exhale and drop your
shoulders and say holy smokes i still
love this guy
and he did all these things and i still
have feelings for him
i don't think any of that stuff is bad
or wrong
but i think you've got to make peace
with i am not going to be with him
therefore i'm not going to be in
communication with him i'm not going to
go on dates with him i'm not going to
sleep with him i'm not going to fill in
the blank with him i have to move on
with my life
we will be connected forever because we
share a child and we're going to be
adults but there is going to come a day
that he calls and says hey me and my
girlfriend are coming over to pick up
our
son and that's gonna be a
one of those moments we can't breathe
and so i think it's about being honest
with where you actually are it sounds
like y'all are on a break the way you
describe him the things he did yes he
was a scumbag yes he said stupid stuff
yes he was unfaithful absolutely
but you still have feelings for him in a
major way and you either need to cut
ties and move on
or you need to sit down with him and be
honest about
here's i'm still here i'm still in this
thing it's the limbo land that's killing
you and so here's the second thing your
mom was right about
uh but in in not the right not a normal
way what's going to be really tough for
your son
is the absorption
of chaos
of your anxiety
your frustration relationally
your pain
and if you're not whole and well and
doing the things and you are you're in
counseling you are working hard i'm so
proud of you it's incredible so proud of
you
but if you are playing ping pong with
your heart with his dad
that's what your son will absorb
that make sense yeah yeah that makes
sense
and so i want you to have some hard
conversations with your own heart and
with yourself
and truly mind yourself if you still got
your therapist do it with them
if you have full trust with him full
trust with him why do you think he
i to finish my sentence here and then
i'll
why
you've got to be honest with yourself
about the status of this relationship
because it feels like there's a
dot-dot-dot after this last breakup
why do you think he invited you to
california
he tells me that he
wants to spend time with
um our son more
and um
you don't believe him well
you don't believe him why do you think
he invited you i don't care what he said
why do you think he invited you
um i think so that we can
act like a family yeah
you can play family and it's super cool
to play family is it going to his family
going to visit friends or family of his
no no just um going to san diego it's a
vacation huh yeah it's so fun to play
family
and then
he can come back to
denver and you go back to doing all of
the work
night and day and he can live his life
and then when he wants to play family
then he gets to
yeah and that's not fair for you and
that's not fair for that baby and it's
not fair for him
yeah you're right
is that fair i know i sound like your
mom and i just got weird for everybody
right
that's exactly what what she told me
so
she's really going to enjoy listening to
this
no
jessica let me tell you this
you're worth your needs being met
you're worth getting to the bottom of
why you're a lot why you're hard in
relationships
and i love that you've been reflective
enough to deal with that i've had to
deal with it too
yeah
i love that you love your baby and you
want him around his dad i hope you never
ever lose that
yeah and i love the fact that you still
love
i really do
but you're gonna have to make some hard
decisions about what the end of a
relationship means for real or if you
want to sit down and be vulnerable and
say hey you've hurt me in really bad
ways
and i still love you
and if you will x y and z i'm still
willing to be all in or not
but you've got to put some periods at
the end of some sentences so you can
start writing new ones for you and your
son
yeah so because i did make a comment
about us being in limbo once and he said
um
he said you're in limbo i know what i
want
and
was it you and i do i feel like i'm the
one that's in limbo like i don't know
yeah you do know if i can trust him yeah
oh he said he wants you yeah he said he
he said you're the one that's in limbo
but when i when we've talked in the past
when i told him well these are my niece
this is what i need from you
he's not willing to do him he's like
that's too much
and i'm like okay well then he's
answering your question for you yeah
yeah i think he's answering your
question
i will tell you that um
infidelities you know no good no bueno
that's that's easy
i know lots of people who've got up and
walked out of
counseling sessions before and that
doesn't mean they're evil people that
means their bodies say i can handle this
right now
yeah and it could be stuff as far back
his childhood it could be stuff as far
back as mom and dad it could be all over
the place
um i know lots of people who did not
handle do not handle postpartum well
does that excuse it no
it means they are uneducated
scared terrified children who now have a
child right yeah does that excuse what
they say no does that make the pain any
less no
but i know people who find themselves
relationally
in situations where they are out of
tools
and well one time i actually
offered one of your episodes to him i
said hey will you listen to this um
he is giving advice to a husband
who has a wife who has postpartum
depression because i think i have
postpartum depression
and his response was
um
he said
really like you don't think i'm doing
enough for you already
and it just shattered me like i have no
words because tears just started
flooding through
because unlike it would have been a
15-minute clip that you could have
listened to
that explained exactly what i needed
from him you're correct
that's it would have been 15 minutes and
explained it
and
some men hear
hey i want you to listen to this other
guy
and he's going to tell you how to be
more of a man for me
and does that mean it's wrong i mean
it's right that he responded that way no
but i also want to be empathetic and
understand how he may have heard that
here's an obnoxious can i be obnoxious
for a second here's an
obnoxious other side to that
what if he saw some woman in the mall
and he said
that's that's the body i'm looking at
that's the one i was thinking of for you
go talk to her about how her workout and
and diet program is
right and you'd be like how about i drag
you into the parking lot run over you
with the car right
and so
um
sometimes we hear things in ways that
aren't really what the what you intend
but that's how they come across
and it that depends on a million again
you run up with a bunch of tools
if he can't hear the the episode okay
that's great i'm not for everybody
maybe you write down on a piece of paper
with bullet points
here's some things that
i heard from a mental health guy
that would really be helpful here
or you take what i said and you write
down bullet points and then you
translate them to here are some things
that i need here's some different ways i
can say what i need
and he's going to have to grow up and
know that if somebody loves you if
you're
if the person you're in love with tells
you here's how you can best love me it
doesn't mean that you're an idiot that's
actually the greatest gift one person in
an intimate relationship can give to the
other is to be explicit on here's my
needs
and if if somebody ever has the courage
to tell you their needs and you take
that personally come on man
be better than that
say thank god now i don't have to really
try to read your mind anymore and it's
not a statement on you failed or you're
a [ __ ] it's just that your person you
love told you hey actually here's what i
need
um
and by the way those needs will change
over the course of your relationship
you're one you're five you're 10 you're
20 whatever and it's man if you find
somebody that will just tell you what
they need oh my gosh it's so great and
i'll be honest the times my wife has
told me that when i was especially when
i was younger it crushed me i thought oh
what a loser i am what a failure and
then my shame shot out and i started
reacting like a child i would be silent
for three days or be grumpy or have an
attitude problem because i was an
immature idiot and so um i don't think
you're done
i don't
do i think this relationship can work if
y'all both wanted to yes does it look
great right now no i don't think it's
smart to go play family in san diego
though i don't think that
i don't i think you'll need to sit down
have a hard direct conversation and then
you have to make some grown-up decisions
[Music]
that's gonna be hard
thanks for calling jessica let us know
in a couple of weeks in a couple of
months how things are going and we'll
walk alongside with you this whole way
we'll be right back on the dr john
dolone show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not and how you can get back
on the road of being whole and well
listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndaloni.com and get
your copy of redefining anxiety today
all right let's go to cassandra in
tacoma washington hey cassandra what's
happening
hi thank you for having me on your show
i really love it
yes that always makes me happy not
not a lot of people love it hey so
what's going on how can i help
so i've had a
multiple
failed romantic relationships resulting
in three wonderful kids they're nine
years apart 21 12 and three
dang gina 21-12 and three
yeah it's a big spread
so um there was a lot of trauma in my
past and so i know
that i was picking emotionally abusive
partners and
that i've done a lot of work to heal it
but like in the process just kept
repeating those kinds of relationships
yeah
um
i feel like i've done a lot of work put
in the work to heal and that i was ready
for a healthy relationship
and uh so i started seeing someone a few
months ago but uh i was struggling with
like not unloading on him about my past
but also like i knew i don't want to
hide my past i
i knew before i met him that i wanted to
meet someone and i had to be brave and a
little vulnerable
and uh
just
i feel like
things came out slowly over
the last couple months in our
conversations and
you know he's been asking a lot of
questions and just um
feeling like he needs time to process
the information
and so i guess my question is i was just
feeling like meaning advice on how i
could have done it better and like what
i can do moving forward
seriously
oh so so how many times have you been
married
three three times okay so you have
you've been married three times and you
have three kids by three different
ex-husbands is that right correct yeah
and how old are you
42 42. okay so you've been married three
times
your first kid when you were 21
and then
okay very cool
and so here you find yourself
um
all three of these marriages dissolved
for
abuse reasons is that right primarily
there's definitely like
a theme of like
addiction and
manipulative behavior my dad was kind of
a mess that way so i picked similar
people sure
and you've heard me say on this show we
so often marry our unfinished business
and our bodies are always running
towards things that are familiar even if
it's not good for us right
and so three times you've looped back
and been with men who hurt you
and
or who weren't safe
and
then you decided to get serious about
healing when did you decide to do that
i'd say it's been like over a decade
even though i was still in one of those
relationships just kept like going back
but through that process kept learning
more and more about codependency again
it's like hoovering and love bombing and
all that yeah
so what do
what have you brought to these three
marriages that you want to be different
in marriage number four
i definitely can improve my
communication i feel like what is that
what does that mean
uh
i feel like i can write really well and
then when i try to talk it's all gambled
and like alphabet soup
okay
do you avoid confrontation
definitely i
would like
kind of freeze i guess
and then you take whatever crap
somebody's addition and then it builds
up and builds up and builds up
yeah and i felt like i definitely felt
like i've been a non-confrontational
person in the past but that i've learned
slowly like through work and things that
it's necessary cool so what happened in
this last one so you started working
about a decade ago
and you got a three-year-old now what
happened in this last relationship
um so i had left him and then shortly
after
became pregnant and just kind of
sorry no it's okay
so you left an unsafe relationship you
all got back together
and then you found out you're pregnant
yeah so i i've always been a terrible
pregnant person like pre-term
labor and gestational diabetes i was
just really scared hold on hold on hold
on hold on you're a terrible pregnant
person or yeah or you get sick
i get sick yeah those are two totally
different things you're not a terrible
pregnant person
you get sick
it's not like a
character or moral defect i'm a terrible
person when i have a lot of junk food i
act like an idiot
i get exhausted i get all bloaty and i
get grumpy that's terrible
just because your body gets sick you're
not terrible
so you get sick when you're pregnant and
so you've had a you had a hard row huh
yeah
so i just knew
i i just
got scared and like
wanted some kind of stability and went
back
yeah
are you safe now
yeah okay
and so then one year two years later you
met who you think's going to be husband
number four
the goal is i don't i i wouldn't say
that i've
like made a decision on that i need i i
know i need to go slowly okay
and get to know someone
and so in the process of getting to know
this person that you you kind of fancy
and you feel is the healthiest you've
ever been
you started on telling them about your
past and the struggles you've had and
the marriages you've had and the kids
you've had
and he said whoa
is that right
yeah
tell me about that
it's just been quiet like
when i've had to say hard things it'll
be quiet and he just explains like he
needs to process
like it feels very respectful and
um that he's
you know he's got a good head on his
shoulders and like i'm glad that he's
being thoughtful about this
what would you like him to do
um
it'd be cool if he gave me a chance
has he said i'm out but i know
no he hasn't it's just been pretty quiet
the last week so he's giving you a
chance
i don't know
it sounds like he's giving you a chance
cassandra here's what it sounds like it
sounds like for the first time in 20
years
you've
you're talking to a guy that doesn't act
like an immature idiot
yeah this definitely doesn't seem like a
man baby
and
this is going to sound nuts what i'm
about to say okay this is one of those
cool ways our bodies are designed but
they can get us trapped in a whole bunch
of mess
we can come to identify
the electricity and the chaos and the
um impact if you will
a fight
of anger of anxiety of depression the
chemical response as our bodies dump
into our system
to deal with those emergencies those
fights the running the freezing all that
we can get addicted to it it can become
the thing that we know
so you've been married three times
you've been loved three times you've had
kids you've had you've been through
childbirth with three different men
and your body remembers what that chaos
was like
and you know that that chaos hurt you
you know that chaos wasn't good for your
kid it wasn't good for the stability of
a relationship but it signaled
love to you signal connection however
wacky that sounds
and now you've met a guy who is
processing and before he pops off at the
mouth
he quietly says i just need some time to
process it this is a lot and i need a
few days
holy smokes did you know if every man on
earth responded like that
everything would be
better tomorrow right
um yeah feels like if he didn't want to
continue
personally me that i still feel really
grateful for having met someone like him
yes and hey i'll tell you there's a
bajillion of them out there
a whole bunch
a whole whole whole bunch
but here's what's happening in your
heart because there's not an electric
response
a loud response a volatile response a an
emotionally abusive response lots of
swear words and volume
there's a part of you however
dysfunctional this sounds
that is that is equating that to this
relationship isn't as good
this one doesn't mean as much this one's
not going to end up in marriage or into
a child or into whatever
and what i
want to encourage you to do and since
you're calling this your first
relationship where you are on a healing
path you're actually
saying what you actually need you're
being honest you're speaking up for
yourself you're not
um walking around in the shadows of your
own relationship and your own value you
are recognizing that your space has
worth
that
you're gonna have to learn how to be in
relationship with somebody who's
emotionally mature
yeah i knew like
from when i was 19
like dr drew used to say like
not to go for the person that gives you
that spark so i know
that's something that's always been in
the back of my mind and that healthy's
gonna feel weird yeah it's gonna feel
different now there is tons of sparks
there are forest fires in
stability and safety you just have to be
intentional about them
they're control burdens right like
farmers control burn their fields and
then sometimes lightning strikes and
burns down the entire community
one of those is good one of those is not
they both involve fire
yeah okay so here's the next part of
risk and i want to applaud you cassandra
and for everybody listening who hasn't
been through three marriages and three
kids and three emotionally and possibly
physically and sexually abusive
relationships and who didn't have a
bunch of childhood trauma
the courage and bravery cassandra you
are showing by getting back up off the
mat after number three and saying i
still have value i still have worth and
i still want connection
is it's strength that very few people on
earth will ever know
and thank you it comes with risk and you
know this intellectually
but your body hates risk all of our
bodies hate risk you especially
because you've been through trauma so
here's the big risk
i want you to call him and say can we
have coffee
or can we go to dinner can we have lunch
whatever that looks like
and i want you to
tell him
i put a lot on you and i know i've got a
pretty wild past
tell me where your heart is right
now do you still like me you still want
to be
my my boyfriend makes you on a date
and when you ask that question
that will be as vulnerable as standing
naked in front of somebody
yeah cause you'll be putting all of the
eggs in his basket
he will be able to say
i don't think this is gonna work for me
and that's gonna hurt like holy hell
and
you will have been honest for the first
time in a relationship
he will you'll have dated somebody who's
honest for the first time in a
relationship and that pain hurts and
that grief will hurt
but that's going to be the first step
towards
this is what healthy feels like this is
what healthy looks like
if i help you and it's scary
scary and here's what's here's what's
almost more scary
if he said yeah i'm still in
i'm still in
then you're gonna go oh gosh now you're
in uncharted water you've never been
with an emotionally mature person
and you're going to be figuring this out
as you go here's the one thing i want
you to keep in mind cassandra two things
number one i've said i'm gonna say it
again you have value and your needs are
important and you're gonna have to
practice being in a healthy relationship
that's number one
and you're gonna have to find a dance
partner who's gonna practice with you by
the way practicing can be tons and tons
and tons of fun
it's just different it's scary
the second thing is this
i want you to keep
i wish when your body takes off on you
when it feels like ah this is all over i
want you just to try to back out of your
body for a second
and just look at your body feel it and
go oh man my heart's racing my head is
spinning out of control
my body's trying to take care of me
thank you body this one's safe
this guy's alright
remember all that work we did on how to
breathe and how to recognize when our
heart rate's taken off on us this is
just for that moment right now
right now
and thank you for taking care of me when
your back starts hurting when your neck
hurts you know you get that weird crick
in your neck
when you wake up 10 days in a row and
your knees hurt i want you to step up
and say
oh body you're trying to take care of me
again thank you thank you for that but i
like this guy
and he's safe
and i'm going in i'm going in it's gone
i'm gonna risk it i'm gonna risk it
and by the way just one more call out
for you cassandra you mentioned
um relational dumping
yes going slow is good
you've had a lot of heavy stuff in your
past
going slow is good not that your past
isn't worthy of being fully heard
but yeah there's a difference between
going slow and walking through people
and answering questions when they ask
them and then just backing a semi up to
their front yard and just
hitting the dump button and be like this
is me and it all just dumps in their
yard that can be overwhelming um you are
worthy of being loved and you are worthy
of being known
and yeah
you've had a wild ride
a lot of people hurt you you've been
through a lot of mess and
slower is better that's wise good for
you cassandra let us know how that
conversation goes please write me back
let me know the conversation goes love
to have you back on the show and
i'd love to have him on the show love to
hear what he's working through and
thinking through
i could always use another emotionally
mature guy
for the world to hear that'd be great
especially on my show because
i'm not always emotionally mature thank
you so much for being brave cassandra
you're awesome awesome awesome all right
as we wrap up today's show
who picked this one
zach
wow
are you a dashboard fan
james
i like one album of theirs which one
a mark a brand a mission a scar that's a
good reason because it's a full band one
i don't love like the acoustic stuff but
the full band one is really great
um can i do this song in his i won't do
it in his voice i won't do that
i'll just read it straight up he lives
in our community i wanted to come by and
be on the show one day
zach you know him
i'm trying to figure out how to work
this thing this is so hard yes no
ladies and gentlemen this is the
expertise i get to work with on a daily
basis we actually found zach in the
parking lot um this isn't the og zach
it's a new zack and he was just walking
around the parking lot i'm like hey man
want to be on a show and he's like okay
and he's playing video games he's
actually in the middle of minecraft
how's it going have you building a city
the look of disappointment that james
just gave me
i i haven't received that this is
now you know how i feel every show
that look at disappointment like whoa my
gosh i went to college i've been
producing shows for a decade and this is
where my career has landed
i get it james all right
zach
the uh stranger
the stranger danger on the computers
whatever you don't even know what you're
doing back there
brings his favorite song of all time
ever
oh now you're shaking your head do you
even know how this show works geez it's
not my favorite at all time well i'm
calling it um dashboard confessional the
song
he picked a song off a soundtrack for
god's sake off this
off a
it's a soundtrack song of a sequel
soundtrack
people who have songs on sequel
soundtracks their own parents don't even
listen to these they're sound but i
can't my kids on the web i looked
through other lyrics and i just didn't
think that they were appropriate for
this show well great off the spider-man
2 soundtrack one that we all have in our
cd carousel
thanks to zack
the song is by dashboard confessional
the song is called the vindicated
oh jeez
hope dangles on a string like a slow
spinning redemption
how do you
winding in and winding out the shine of
it has caught my eye and roped me in
so mesmerizing so hypnotizing i'm
captivated i am vindicated i am selfish
i am wrong i am right i swear i'm right
i swear i knew it all along but i'm
flawed but i'm cleaning up so well i
seeing in me now the things you swore
you saw yourself
how did you
gosh hey
this is the dr john dolone show part two
stay tuned